I also know in reading a little bit of
your history coming up that you you grew
up with the church I did yes so I would
imagine that the this is not uh this
doesn't
coincide the church could be pretty uh
militant against what you do you find
that have they are you being attacked or
not yet CRI not yet not yet you're
already known I'm going to tell you I'm
going to tell you not yet for a reason
in an hour so I I I will tell you that
I've been very very lucky and when I say
lucky I think it's because of the way
the way that I do what I do somebody
early on wanted me to start a church I
kid you not they wanted me to start a
church and they said start a church
start a church they said you should be a
a minister or like a preacher and I was
like why and they said oh my God you'll
have a super a mega church a super
church I don't call me churchurch you
can call yours it's yours you can call
it whatever you want it was like a mega
church he go because you could preach
the Bible and then you can demonstrate
you know and they were like you can
demonstrate and that's just going to
like you know and I looked at the person
I was like yeah you clearly don't get me
and they were like what I go I want to
see the person and then I want to see
them leave like I am not looking for a
dependency on them if somebody doesn't
come back and see me that means I did my
job well enough that they don't feel the
need to come back and see me I go I
don't want to Foster any type of
dependency anywhere energetically or or
whatnot like that to me is a that was a
big like whoa red flag so my Catholic
upbringing um got in the way maybe in my
family Dynamic cuz my mom was divorced
and she would sit in the back of the
church and I'd be like why are you sit
in the back you want to sit in the back
cuz you want to sit in the back and
she's like I shouldn't even be in the
building I'm like why shouldn't you be
in the building and she goes well I'm
excommunicated cuz I'm divorced and I
was like you know that's like just
man-made silliness right and she was
like well it is what it is and I come
from the the the Catholic background
that if you missed mass and you did not
go to confession you could not receive
the host on Sunday there was no no Act
of Contrition as you're walking down the
hall you're like walking down the aisle
so it was a pretty serious like my
grandmother took me to church every day
until I was in first grade so the church
and the Catholic religion the dogmatic
belief system was very much a part of my
upbringing and then I kind of felt like
I was also just by nature of what I what
I chose excommunicated never affected my
faith but it did affect the rules so I
I'm a rule I was like these are the
rules okay and then I had a nun come to
me um she was my 2:00 appointment and
she showed up in full-on habit like and
I I thought she was collecting for a
charity or something and I said can I
help you and she said you can if you're
John I said I am John I go how can I
help you and she said I'm your 2:00 and
I remember
thinking oh okay come in so she comes in
I bring her in the room that I'm reading
in I wasn't married yet I sat her down
and I ran into the other room and I
called my wife now my girlfriend and now
wife at work and I was like s and ra
there is a nun here and she's like okay
she's like why is she there and I go for
a reading she's like my 2:00 appointment
and she goes so then go read her and I
was like yeah but like I'm like
completely distracted right now and she
goes why is she topless and I was like
no she's not topless I go she's like
full on in her habit and the whole
wimple thing she's like John I am at
work go do your job and I went and I sat
down and I did the reading I was really
professional right and at the end of the
reading she got really quiet and she
said do you know why I'm here I looked
at her went I'm assuming because you
wanted to hear from these people and she
said no I was here to have you
arrested and I went
oh okay and she said you have been
reading a lot of my parishioners and I
run a support and grief bement group she
goes and your name keeps coming up over
and they're passing it around she said
and I needed to make sure that you
weren't taking advantage of them and I
went okay and I'm looking at her like I
don't know which way this is going cuz
she was very again very Nish um and I
said to her I said well how's my day
looking you know I tried to crack a joke
and she said it's very clear that God
gives people gifts she goes and you have
one and it's very clear that you're
using it to help people in the right in
the right way and I and I was like well
thank you I said I I do the best I can
and then um she says how she goes how
how much how much is this whatever and I
was like oh no not this is this is
nothing and she was like that was the
right
answer and then she proceeded to tell me
that I would be working with her and I
would be supporting her in her grief
group at the convent that she worked at
and I did that for years after that and
then my day ended with a priest same
day that's so bizarre and that's such a
dichotomy between what you do and what
is kind
of I I don't know I'm a Jew but you know
what I would think that the Catholic
church but I feel like I I felt like you
know I said to the priest at the end of
the day ago who by the way is still a
very good friend of mine I was like why
do you think on the same day like a nun
and a priest were sent to me he goes cuz
you were a drift at Sea and you were
lost so we were sent in universally he
goes you would say the Universe I would
say Jesus call it what you like you
needed help here we are and I thought
that was a cool
thing
he